german chancellor of schultz is looking
to senegal to help european countries
wean their dependence off russian fuel
the country is believed to have
significant deposits of natural gas
during a joint news conference with
senegalese president
expressed interest in a gas exploitation
project that could bring the first
barrels by next year the german
chancellor is heading to niger and south
africa next which has pledged to phase
out its use of cost fossil fuels
olaf schultz's visit has been dominated
by issues surrounding the war in ukraine
high on the agenda for his meeting with
senegal's president marquis saul was the
critical issue of food security
the war has sent grain prices soaring
and seoul will soon travel to russia and
ukraine on behalf of the african union
hoping to secure blocked supplies
as chairman of the african union i
expressed to chancellor schultz our
serious concerns about the impact of the
war on our countries african countries
including the widespread price spikes
and shortages that we are currently
seeing
schultz has vowed to help get exports
moving again
this is currently being discussed very
intensively
despite this terrible conflict we need
cooperation so that a country which is
currently defending itself against a war
of aggression can successfully deliver
it's important that we make the attempt
otherwise there is a great danger that
many countries in the world will have
extreme difficulty in feeding their
populations
also under discussion energy germany
offered to help develop natural gas
production of senegal's coast
the west african country has large
reserves and berlin sees them as a
possible alternative to russian gas
after zenegal schultz will travel to
niger before finishing the three-day
visit in south africa
germany is in desperate search of
natural gas now it's ready to break
certain taboos to find it including
drilling off its own coast including
inside the waden sea which is known for
its rich biodiversity that's creating
mixed emotions among people living there
dw's stephen beardsley reports from the
island of borkum in the north sea
for more than three decades alberta's
aquaman has guided school classes and
tourists into the title flats here
it's a landscape that stretches across
europe's north sea coast and is
protected by national parks in denmark
and germany
it's incredibly rich in flora and fauna
these are risks that personally make me
very very fearful
these are real fears that there'll be
long lasting damage done to our island
foundation and at a time when sea levels
are rising
and now we're digging something out
that's just not sustainable
borkum thrives from tourism which comes
because of its nature and not just the
tidal flats but clean expansive beaches
an island population of 5 000 can swell
to as many as 35 000 people during high
season
the regional government in hanover had
outright rejected drilling
now it supports the project saying that
the war has made it necessary
the gas drilling firm juan diaz projects
there are 60 billion cubic meters of
natural gas in the reserve which
straddles the dutch border the platform
will stand 20 kilometers off borkum and
it will avoid nearby national park
territory
here in borkham residents often mention
the nearby city of groningen in the
netherlands
that's where extensive gas drilling has
led to hundreds of small earthquakes
over the years destabilizing homes and
angering the population
those earthquakes were unforeseen
the ceo of the drilling firm says his
company has already conducted
environmental assessments and that the
comparison with groningen where gas
reserves are located directly under the
region is unfair the subsidence has been
of course uh investigated and there will
be no subsidence underneath the islands
or the structures underneath the island
because the reservoir doesn't get close
to the island the reservoir from where
we produce
the gas
residents in borkum also use gas and say
they understand that it needs to be
affordable just not why drilling has to
happen off their coast
on the mainland they may say well sure
let them drill for gas up the coast of
baucom what's it to me but not when you
live here sure 20 kilometers may not
seem like a big deal but you can
understand the islanders who look at
this critically and have real misgivings
but this time they fear world events are
moving faster than they can react to
them
you